a los ojos de China una amenaza a su
soberanía para Estados Unidos un acto
diplomático común
tras su visita a Guatemala y Belice la
presidenta de Taiwán Sáenz aterrizó en
California donde se reunió con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy la tercera figura política más
importante de Estados Unidos
creo que nuestro vínculo es más fuerte
ahora que en cualquier otro momento de
la historia y por supuesto la presidenta
es una gran campeona Taiwán es una
democracia exitosa una economía próspera
y un líder Global en salud y ciencia a
su vez hay aseguró que mantenerse Unidos
los hace más fuertes
no es un secreto la paz que hemos
mantenido y la democracia en la que
hemos trabajado han enfrentado desafíos
sin precedentes Taiwán se esfuerza por
ser un socio confiable para el mundo una
piedra angular para la estabilidad en la
región hoy mismo la Casa Blanca calificó
la visita de un acto común de diplomacia
hemos dicho que no hay razón para que
Beijing convierta este tránsito en algo
usado como pretexto para sobre
reaccionar hemos sido claro
desde que se anunció la gira de Cyborg
Centroamérica china aseguró que una
reunión con mccarthy acarrearía medidas
firmes ya en 2022 la visita Taiwán del
entonces presidenta del órgano
legislativo Nancy pelosi fue calificada
de traición deplorable por Beijing que
además sancionó a la funcionaria y
aumentó sus maniobras militares en el
estrecho de Taiwán
La Isla es uno de los mayores motivos de
conflicto entre China y Estados Unidos
principalmente porque Washington es el
mayor proveedor de armas de Taiwán